when you go on tour you get um
sort of like um
used to the heat and all that before you
get dispersed out to your operations
um so as soon as i got dispersed out to
my operations within three weeks i took
that shot which i didn't know i bought
the world record when did you know you
broke the record who told you did
somebody whisper to you or
no no when i when i came back
to um england
we we have a medals parade like you get
your ribbons and all that to say welcome
home
and the the media is welcome into the
camp
to interview you and talk to you and um
i spoke to this gentleman
and i said that
you know i was a sniper also a sergeant
in charge of these guys and he said can
you tell me a story and i told him the
story of my shot and he said you realize
you built the world record you beat rob
furlon's record
the canadian guy um by you know a long
way and i went no i didn't and when it
went into the papers
that's when we me and my wife got death
threats
and we had to go in hiding for three
years
oh because they put it in the papers
and you don't as a sniper you definitely
don't want that
no it was my wife's name my daughter's
name my dog's name
where i lived where i was born where i
was raised up everything everything was
in the papers i'm not funny enough my
wife said i've got a bad feeling about
this i've got a bad feeling about this
and everyone just kept saying to her you
know it's fine it's fine it's fine and
then
um
i there was another clip in the paper
because of the two guys that i shot were
taliban leaders
um they wanted to cut my head off and um
kidnapped me
and uh to just to um teach me a lesson
and so what did you guys have to move
just to make sure you were safe did you
go to a different place so they couldn't
uh yeah we went into secure housing and
then we moved to america for three years
just for that one event and this is two
people you took out right at this event
it's uh yes it is yeah two people and
the 2004 75 for for some people that
maybe can't visually see what that's
about a half a half a mile what we're
talking about right just over a mile and
a half yeah just over a mile and a half
is what that's a mile and a half is what
we're talking about so yeah so two there
80 total 13 in that one afghanistan
what was the biggest difference between
the first
kill versus the last one first uh
confirmed kill versus the last one was
there a big difference
emotionally
where the last one is like you know boom
it's a job i'm moving on the first one
you're like oh my gosh
did i do you know what was the biggest
difference for you
that one you
when i first um
[Music]
when i first got first shot
and
you know and on onto my target you feel
like you're in trouble
you feel like you're in trouble you
think christ i've killed someone
you know um
somebody's going to tap me on the
shoulder and say you know can we have a
quick word of you you know why did you
do this why did you do that because
i didn't know you know it's my job at
the time and
and then you don't get blase but you
sort of get into the rhythm of things
when you're taking targets out you don't
look at them as human beings you just
look them as as
as the job the operation that you need
to do to take that target out
is is there any one of them that you had
to do where there were uh uh
it was so technical because there were
kids involved and you had to try to get
the target that you had uh
in a climate where their kids around and
the only reason i think about this i
think about it from the movie you know
the movie with uh
uh
yeah where i interviewed his wife i had
her on taya
and you know that one scene where
there's kids is like oh my gosh how do i
do it what do i do in this angle was
there ever a you know situation like
that that you were in
yeah there was yeah in um
in iraq
um in in basel itself where it was in a
place
um a little place called the p jock
and there was only um
like 12 of us at this location and it
was a police station basically and
every time every night
the
insurgents used to come up and try and
break into the prison to release all the
people in the prison
so our job was to take the insurgents
out but from
11 o'clock at night or 5 o'clock in the
morning it was like the gates of hell
so when you
when five o'clock comes
the marketplace opens
and then you get everyone it's really
busy got it you know but you can still
see your targets so you end up tracking
them
you end up tracking them you end up
observing you end up um finding out
where they go where they hold up and
when the night comes you're back on that
target and where they are and you end up
taking that target out
it's wild just thinking about it you
know on that war was there any any one
of the 80 that
you
afterwards minus the first one because
it's the first one you're experiencing
was there any one of them where you
relive quite a lot in your own mind one
that you constantly think about or no
yeah yeah
it's hard to talk about
okay so there is there is something that
in your mind it goes back and is it more
about something where i should have done
it this way i should have done it that
way or was it just a setting that uh you
keep reliving
just
just the whole scenario i should have
done it different you know so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]